hello and welcome to this video would
Pasha what pusher 2010 it's my opponent
ok i'm happy with the NIMS oh but I want
to do I don't want the book away again
something else someone suggested the
blumenfeld which is quite risky but
let's give it a go I think I think I'm
taking here right I actually studied
this opening once it's just it's just
try to go andy sixx i believe was what i
was looking at
I think we should be seven but it's kind
of fuzzy in my mind before is hanging so
yeah it's playing I think exactly the
main line there that is slightly better
for wine if my memory serves me
correctly there
yeah that's a problem sometimes with
those offbeat line some if someone just
know stuff and you're just worse at
least a bit worse depends on the line
but here why does a bit better okay i
was thinking i can delay the recapture
it maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong okay
this absolutely no denying here that he
wants to kill me outright yeah without
any kind of mercy in mind not sure that
it is that great to be honest okay let
me take that pawn yeah I like my pair of
bishops but I don't like the d6 porn
this is an issue
95 he will take play nazi form hmm i
don't want to play Knight b6 well I
heard it looks wrong I want to fight
actually he's not he's not entirely off
with the drawer I mean I don't like my
position but still want to fight a
little bit there are some scenarios that
I ok like if we trade stuff here and I
get this n five maybe oops number three
okay didn't go for it this is can get
interesting if five might still be an
option between a five if I have I can
take no cannot take me what to do with
that mission
you
before coming night be three crew before
was my idea not sure that 93 is any good
but I can also go to see 3 by the way
now that's even better k Quincy three
here he gets the night to see four at
the end okay
let's push this away now wow really that
looks self finish
you
really feel like it should be possible
to exploit this looks that looks bad and
wrong don't see anything that one my
time is ticking down check Queen d2
submitting me check okay one minute Oh 3
that's the thing time working check
a-rod's I learned yeah rah rah yeah I
played it in a very simple way at the
end because I felt that if I do it
complicated i probably lose on time I'm
I can do stuff with the two bishops
maybe but I had no time on the clock and
somewhere here probably had more that
looked really bad we should be too then
f5 yes yeah yeah this is very nice an f5
mmm yeah okay so tricky business I think
here wyd normally doesn't take but ok
and also interesting I'm getting it back
here I feel like it should be should be
ok this position about equal maybe I
should have actually still played this
the engine just gives Queenie 7 that's
not a bad idea 9525 is actually fine and
my ideas maybe bishop p + f5 I like that
that's a good position equal my probably
kind of okay I had this idea and here
also felt kind of okay 'if I've was
interesting but he didn't go for that I
was I had some may I had some doubts
about this here maybe for me what seems
to be okay and this happened Queen 85 he
went for that wacky self pen yeah my mic
my time was check wasn't it Shannon this
is a good end game that he played one
very weird move g3 allowing this kind of
thing but ok it seems we should be to a
son is
o que se SE se yeah I could have tried
more objectively on in this end game
from the positioner from the pure
position point of view but there was a
bit I was a bit skeptical because of the
the time situation okay well thanks for
watching